the problem I have with this country is
we're not a serious country when we talk
about social and cultural problems much
of the world is talking about the
demographic Time Bomb much of the world
is talking about aging societies much of
the world is talking about how to
develop pro-family policies but in
Britain where our national conversation
is dominated by social liberals and
progressives who will basically use this
to try and stain people as being you
know right-wing or Victor or band
sympathizers or whatever we're just not
a serious country we're not even capable
of having the policy debates that we
need to have in order to solve these
problems